if Jesus was alive today and he did his
whole thing today you know who he would
hang out with he would hang out with
furries he would hang out with sex
workers he would hang out with drag
queens he would hang out with party kids
at Raves and in BDSM clubs he would hang
out in all those places that the pious
Pharisees despise he hung out with women
which were one of the most marginalized
groups of the time he would not go to
the Republic National Convention okay
put a PO so he he was right up until
that part you know where Jesus would be
if he were alive he would be in places
where Sinners are he is man God is every
he's just begging you to to turn to him
and to accept his grace he's begging you
and he he will meet you in the lowest
most disgusting degenerate Place far
worse places even than that guy can name
he's especially there that's very true
where he goes wrong though is he says he
wouldn't be at the Republican National
Convention no he's there too he is there
he's there he's he's alive